what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about one of my favorite
characters in all of anime bond from the
seven deadly sins make sure to smash
that like button for more seven deadly
sins if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss any new videos as always
leave suggestions for other videos you
would like to see in the comments for
even more seven deadly sins content
conversations and crucial updates follow
us on instagram at anime uproar keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers in
this video so if you're familiar with
this channel you know that the life of
series is where I take some of my fear
characters in anime like Eskin or the
wizard King and albon and talk about
their inspiring lives the goal is to not
only provide you with information about
the characters life but to inspire the
idea is that we can derive motivation
and guidance from these epic characters
and their inspirational stories so let's
turn to bond who wasn't always the
inspiring man he is today bond started
from the bottom even lower than Drake as
a kid bond lived with an abusive father
and what appears to be an indifferent
mother who was prone to drinking his
father beat him frequently and forced
him to not only steal food for himself
but for his parents too his parents
never helped him he had to fend for
himself and then while putting up with
abuse if he tried to sleep
his father would kick him in the stomach
so even when he was tired he had a fear
of falling asleep when he get caught
stealing he would get beaten to a pulp
by other grown men this was difficult on
a physical level but it must have been
just as difficult on an emotional level
eventually he was thrown into a prison
in prison a man offered him some food
bond was so hungry he gobbled it down
this man was named Javad oh he told bond
that he was gonna escape from prison and
invited bond to come with him but
initially you can see that bond is not
very trusting probably because he's been
treated so poorly by other people that
he finds it hard to believe that anyone
would help him immediately zhivago
noticed that because of his
circumstances bond was forced to grow up
fast when he looked that bond he noticed
that his eyes weren't the eyes of a
youngster nevertheless Javad will
continued to treat bottle with kindness
and eventually bond did let his guard
down and begin to trust arago he broke
out of jail
and in one scene while kid bond is
eating he even tells Avago to eat too he
was starting to care for Scirocco as
well one of the first people to show him
kindness someone who would actually give
him food rather than beat him up for
trying to take it when he gets home
though he is beaten up by his dad for
eating by himself instead of bringing
his parents food his dad beats him up
until kid Vaughn pukes
and then they insult him and kick him
out of the house for eating his own puke
another lady pretends to be nice to bond
but only does so so that she can kidnap
him she wants money from an aristocrat
who supposedly wants to torture and kill
kids like bond again jaraguá is the one
who comes to the rescue
accidentally this time as he's
conducting his highway robbery business
he ties up the people who tried to
kidnap bond and his surprise when bond
pops out of one of the barrels
she vago takes bond with him and gives
him food again
bond gets sleepy and is trying to stay
awake because his dad kicks him when he
sleeps
but Chuvalo says he'll watch over him so
he doesn't need to worry
Javad wood decides to help teach bond
how to steal and tells him a story about
the Fountain of Youth in the fairy Kings
forest which is kind of like the holy
grail for thieves because so many people
are after it after Siobhan reveals to
bond that he has a son bond gets a bit
awkward and jealous but Javon says he
also has a kid who looks and sounds
rough in his standoffish name bond bond
blushes he's touched he probably never
had someone say something so nice to him
in his entire life she Bible goes on to
tell bond not to trust anyone but bond
says he trusts Jamaa go Javon go hugs
bond probably wanted a few or only hugs
he got in his life up to this point and
tells him to get some sleep because they
have thieving early in the morning bond
isn't a great mood the next day and
smiling because he finally has a parent
figure who cares about him Shyvana is
late so bond thinks he'll start stealing
the treasure they were gonna steal
together on his own so he can surprise
Chicago and get praised by him however
he's caught by the time Chicago who
overslept gets to the scene bond is
being beaten up worse than usual Shivaji
also hears that people are hunting for a
werefox boy who is actually his son
Jeeva go has to make the decision of who
to save and he decides to try
save his actual biological son rather
than bond he uses his own where beast
form to try and make it in time to save
his son but he's crying the whole time
he hates himself for letting down bond
despite the fact that bond trusted him
in the end he was too late to save his
real son and he feared that bond was
beaten to death but actually survives
but he's lost the most important thing
in his life just as bond began to feel
like he had a true father who cared
about him Jevon go disappeared from his
life about ten years later inspired by
Zhivago story about a treasure guarded
by a saint bond now referred to as bond
the Bandit sets out to steal the
Fountain of Youth he wants eternal life
because he thinks if he lived long
enough chances are something good would
happen to him eventually he meets the
saint of the forest who immediately
proceeds to seemingly send him flying to
his death but the forest saves bond
after the Saint Alain tells bond that
the forest would die if he took the
Fountain of Youth he decides to give up
on stealing it
Alain reads his mind to see if he's
telling the truth and he is to her
surprise Alain and Vaughan develop a
relationship they can bond over the fact
that nothing good seems to happen to
them in their lives
Vaughn's upbringing was tough while the
only person that cared about him she
vago disappeared without a trace
soon after they met while Alain has been
bored and lonely for the last 700 years
since she has had to watch over the
forest and to found them youth in place
of her absent brother the fairy King
Harlequin bond reads to her from his
book about different drinks he likes and
he tells her stories Alain loves to ear
she gets sad when she thinks about the
fact that they are already halfway
through the book she wishes that bond
came to steal her and not the Fountain
of Youth bond overhears her and says and
how about I do that bond says he doesn't
get along all that well with other folks
and Alain actually took the time to
listen to him Vaughan promises to find
Elaine's fairy King brother and bring
him back so that Alain can be free Alain
hugs bond it's clear they both love each
other these two extremely lonely people
have found each other and as a result
they're no longer lonely things seem
like they're finally turning around for
bond but next thing you know a red demon
attacks bond steals its heart but Dean
have multiple hearts all he did was draw
the demon's attention to him and Elaine
the demon turns around and gives both
Elaine and bond mortal wounds at this
point Elaine tries to save bond she begs
him to take what he came for the
Fountain of Youth she wants him to live
on
however bond refuses and insists that
she drink it and survive Elaine appears
to drink it but then kisses bond and
through the kiss passes the drink to his
mouth because of Elaine bond has become
an immortal he got what he came for but
at this moment it's the last thing he
wanted he uses his new powers to defeat
the red demon as Elaine is dying in his
arms she tells bond to plant the last
seed of the forest somewhere so it can
grow again
she tells bond she was so happy when he
suggested he'd steal her away she wants
to hear him say it one more time but she
passes away before he can even finish
later bond gets arrested because
everyone believes that to satisfy his
own greed he destroyed the fairy Kings
forest and took the Fountain of Youth
for himself they also believe that he
murdered the saint who protected it
meaning Elaine when they are about to
execute him bond doesn't bother to
defend himself he just points out that
they got his name wrong he is no longer
bond abandoned he is now Bondi Undead so
bond ended up getting exactly what he
came to the fairy forest for but
ironically he feels worse than ever
he lost Siobhan go but he was hopeful
when he got to the fairy Kings forest
then he met Elaine the love of his life
and just as they were opening up about
their true feelings she will snatch from
him as well of course bond doesn't care
if they capture him torture him or try
to kill him at this point
yes he's immortal but there's more to it
not only has his upbringing been tough
the only two times he got close to
people they disappeared from his life no
physical pain could match the emotional
pain he's been through if anything the
physical pain might take some of the
focus off the emotional pain he
constantly carries with him this is why
he willingly allows himself to be
captured even if he could escape at any
time fast-forward for years this is
still 16 years before the actual events
of the main story start and bond still
in jail and has
executed a total number of 33 times
except because of his immortality they
were all failed executions he survived
beheading burning and anything else that
jailers could think of Mele Otis comes
to see bond in jail to meet this
immortal man for himself bond thinks
it's another executioner he doesn't feel
like moving so he asks Mele Otis to
execute him in the prison then he
notices that the person who entered is a
kid or at least looks like one Mele Otis
says that he's come to free him bond
says he's got nobody to see no family to
come home to he tells Mele Otis to scram
because he's not trying to escape from
jail there's nothing for him on the
outside then Mele Otis says he'll just
have to kick him out in the prison bond
looks amused by the thought of a kid
being able to kick him out but the demon
Mele Otis has no trouble doing it bond
is excited he enjoyed the fight and
wants to do it again
Mele Otis says it's one zero and that if
bond wants more then he has to come with
Mele Otis and that is how one of the
greatest bromances in anime began with
Mele Otis beating up a depressed bond
and managing to get him to smile and
laugh in the process so far bond has had
a father figure and a lover but he
hasn't had a real friend Mele Otis
filled that role bond joined the seven
deadly sins and became the captain's
best friend given how few people cared
about bond in his life you can imagine
how much Mele Otis's friendship meant to
him at some point after this bond got
drunk and pulled a prank he stole all of
the stuffed animals in the kingdom fairy
king Harlequin was Mad King points out
that each and every one of the stuffed
animals is filled with memories and love
of the children who owned them he calls
Bonnie terrible monster in response bond
opens a stuffed animal up and says
they're actually filled with stuffing
and old rags King calls Bonnie monster
for his actions while Hawk calls him a
real horror but Bob's actions make more
sense when you know his background he
never had a childhood
he got punches and kicks to the gut
instead of stuffed animals as a result
he doesn't know how meaningful these old
rags as he calls them can be to kids
after this incident
King continues to follow bond around so
he can clean up the mess he makes Mel
Yoda says they actually made a pretty
good
some years later ten years before the
main story takes place bought and the
rest of the sins are framed for killing
the great holy nights are us Mele Otis
orders the sins including bond to
disperse and reconvene at a later time
however time passed by without Mellie
Otis meeting up with bond bond began to
believe that Mellie Otis was dead like
when Elaine died he let himself be
captured willingly five years after the
framing according to him he let himself
be captured because he craved the pain
he wanted the kind of suffering that
would make him feel truly alive again he
needed to take his mind off of his
emotional suffering but when he learns
that Mellie Otis his best friend is
actually alive he breaks the door down
immediately and frees himself bond and
Mellie Otis are ecstatic when they meet
again and immediately begin to fight
both claiming that they have 361 wins
out of 720 after the match bond tells
Mellie Otis that he's happy to see him
bond joins the sins on their adventures
while the gang is searching for King
Vaughn gets stabbed by a kid who thinks
bond wants to steal his sister when bond
was actually helping her after realizing
his mistake the kid asks how he can
atone for his sins
however bonds wound heals as if nothing
happened he says true sins can't be
atoned for I believe that this is a very
important quote of bonds that shows the
way he views the world at this point he
blames himself for Elaine's death and he
believes there's no way for him to atone
for it the King shows up and stabs bond
with his spear as a greeting at this
point King thinks that bond killed
Elaine Kings sister for the Fountain of
Youth King calls it a grave grave sin
both want to go to the capital of the
Dead where Dead Souls reside to see
Elaine again in the capital of the Dead
King reveals to bond that Elaine was his
sister and that he wants revenge
he uses his spirit spear hoping to turn
bond into a stone statue for eternity
he asks bond if he has any last words
but bond just grins he doesn't defend
himself and explain what actually
happened because he blames himself too
he blames himself for not being able to
protect the lane in fact if he didn't
draw the red demons attention to them
all those years ago
she might have still been alive so bond
willingly accepts King's punishment and
gladly turns to stone however a
shows up kisses bond and breaks the
curse in the process bond can see her
but King can't
Elaine explains that the living have to
have a strong bond between them for the
deceased to be seen this is why bond can
see her because their bond is so strong
well she is still upset with Harlequin
for abandoning the Kings forest then
bond lets Elaine know that he came to
tell her something
he finishes saying what he wanted to say
about 20 years ago but couldn't because
Elaine passed away before he was
finished he tells her that as she wished
for so long ago he will steal her away
and make her his elaine blushes sheds a
tear of joy and thanks bond
Elaine later tells Harlequin that after
he left she spent her life seven hundred
years of it in complete and utter
isolation
however bond buried all that loneliness
in just seven days she explains to King
that bond provoked King into attacking
him because he was her brother and that
he's not the kind of man King thinks he
is the last thing Elaine asks is for
King to help out and protect bond no
matter what
after they defeat Gila Elaine let's bond
know that she was happy to see him again
bond says he'll see her around and she
kisses him goodbye
later after berserk mode meliodas fought
he'll drop bond and King are training
together and get to talking bond reveals
that he's helping the kingdom but he's
after the trumpet of sin who knows
that's beneath the kingdom he wants to
use that to contact the goddesses and
have them resurrect Elaine King also
brings up his doubts about meliodas
after seeing him in berserk mode he
wonders if he really is a demon this
makes bond furious he says he'll knock
out all of Kings teeth if he keeps
talking about the captain like that he
thinks he could never be a demon he
could never be like that monster
referring to the red demon that killed
Elaine twenty years ago
of course King is right bond is bothered
precisely because it seems like his best
friend could be a demon and bond hates
demons because a demon took away the
love of his life bond reveals how he
feels about the captain he says the
captain told me to come with him a guy
like me who's lived his entire life like
a shun piece of garbage in the whole
wide world
the only whimsical oddballs like that
are Elaine and the captain although he
doesn't say it Shiva
was in this category as well but Vaughn
doesn't know why he disappeared all
those years ago nevertheless this scene
serves to emphasize the fact that Alain
and the captain are the two most
important people in Vaughn's life this
makes what happens later all the more
difficult for bond bond eventually makes
it to the trumpet he asks the goddess's
to take his life in place of Elaine's
however the goddesses say that they are
not interested in bonds life for them to
bring back Elaine bond must kill Mellie
Otis bond is shocked in order to bring
back Elaine he has to kill the other
most important person in his life his
best friend Mellie Otis before one time
when bond got drunk he told Mellie Otis
that he would do anything for a lane it
seems like he was being honest since he
decides to kill his best friend to bring
her back
this must be excruciating for bond he
couldn't protect Elaine and now in order
to bring her back he's attacking someone
he loves he even says he loves the
captain as he snatches away his arm this
is even more meaningful because bond has
never used the word loved like that
before
bond is going for the kill and Mellie
Otis understands he says just as there
are some things bond can't relinquish
there are some things he can't
relinquish either while bond is thinking
about Elaine Mellie Otis has to think
about Elizabeth during this fight bond
admits that Mellie Otis is his best
friend but he asks what is he supposed
to do he came to the realization that
he'll be alone forever that he won't get
the sea lane again whether on this plane
or the next and for bond a world without
her is no better than hell finally he
has a chance to bring her back by
killing Mellie Otis
however bond agrees to postpone the
fight for after they've settled the
matter at hand and rescued Elizabeth
bond goes on to save Jerico
turning her back into a human she has
been obsessed with bond ever since he
undressed her during his escape from
prison and after this she will only get
more attached to him during the battle
against hendrickson bond is brought to
tears when Hawk takes a seemingly lethal
attack in Mellie Otis's place bond is
devastated that such a good guy like
Hawk was killed after the battle bond is
very sad because of all the mean things
he set the heart like that they weren't
friends just because Hawk was trying to
reason with him and stop him from
killing Mellie Otis then
he says everyone I've ever liked always
leaves me he is furious at the unfeeling
gopher who suggests that Hawks death was
a lucky stroke for them bond is so
touched when Hawk finally turns out to
be alive that he's brought to tears
again afterwards bond doesn't try to
kill Mellie Otis but he decides that he
has to leave the seven deadly sins after
having attempted to kill his best friend
Mellie Otis ready to drop the whole
thing hopes bond is joking but bond lets
him know he's serious
one day he turns to the house says
goodbye to the captain and Hawk and then
turns to go bond makes his way to the
new ferry forest he planted he has been
routinely visiting the forest to feed it
the Fountain of Youth in his blood so it
can keep growing as a result many
fairies have come to view him as the
king of the fairies in Harlequins
absence Harlequin believing that the
forest burned down decides to tag along
to see what Bond is talking about and
Jericho who's following bond ends up tag
along - despite king often referring to
bond as an evil or bad guy bond actually
fulfilled
Alain's wish and saved the fairy forest
while the fairies have come to hate
Harlequin because of his long absence
bond reveals that Elaine's body still
rests in the forest he visits it and
promises her lifeless body again that he
will bring her back to life whatever it
takes
clearly bond feels terrible about trying
to kill his best friend when the fairies
claimed that Harlequin is not fit to be
king bond asks them if he tried to kill
his only friend to bring one girl back
to life does he have what it takes to be
king clearly his conscience is still
knowing at vaughan for attempting to
kill Melly Otis yet another sin he's
committed in his life that he thinks he
can't atone for he thinks he was to
blame for his lovers death and he tried
to willingly kill his best friend later
bond runs into a werefox who of course
turns out to be Siobhan oh the only real
father bond ever had this reunion and
reveal is one of the most touching in
the series and one of my favorite
moments she Vogel feels horrible for
abandoning bond to try and save his son
that day but bond reveals that he never
once bore any kind of grudge against
Siobhan oh he was the best father he
could have asked for and this brings
Siobhan go to tears he's so happy that
bonds alive and that he's
to see how big he's grown Shivaji helps
bond with his feelings about meliodas
Jeeva go tells him that no matter how
much he regrets what he did unless he
let smelly Otis know it won't amount to
anything he advises his son not to keep
it all in but to let it out and then beg
for forgiveness and with that
Jeeva who passes away because molasse
Kela is using her powers to resurrect
that Souls Alain comes back to life
temporarily
however the magic that brought her back
has corrupted her amplifying her regrets
and rage so she gets unnaturally jealous
and violent she attacks bond and Jericho
who says that she also loves bond it's
clear that bond cares about Jericho
because he tries to keep Alain from
killing her for bond Jericho is like a
sister to him
in fact she reminds him of a sister he
had and looked out for when he was
really young however his love for Alain
never falters he says that he accepts
the dark side of her along with
everything else
Milosh Kula ends up showing up but her
commandment which burns the eyes of
those who lose their faith in the thing
they believe in has no effect on bond
bond has faith in a lane and that faith
never faltered even after she attacked
him in Jericho moleska points out that
despite everything bonds been through he
has an innocent and beautiful soul
nevertheless she can't kill him because
even though his body is immortal she can
still eat his soul and she's about to
eat it ghal and jumps in and seemingly
eats bond soul however it was actually
Jeeva go soul who sacrificed his own
soul so bond could escape despite the
fact that it would mean he wouldn't be
able to see his biological son
Jeeva go wants to make it up to bond for
not coming to his rescue before
Jeeva go tells bond that he's also his
precious son he tells him to live for
his lover and his friends thinking about
Jamal's final act bond can't help but
cry bond ends up listening to Jeeva go
during the great fight festival Ark bond
and melio to see each other again
and used their usual greeting again Mel
Yodas acts like nothing happened between
them like everything is the same as
before he even thinks it's great that
bond got to see Elena again bond
following sure Vagos advice tells Melly
Otis he's sorry after this their
friendship is finally repaired and bond
can be by melioidosis side again with
now being overcome by guilt in addition
to making up with his best friend bond
has noticed that there's a large gap
between their strengths now
in fact bonds been relatively weak for a
while now while s Canora could easily
defeat gland Amal ask Allah it was all
bond could do to run away from them
his powerlessness reaches a climax when
he can't save his best friend from
Esther OSA he tries his best but he
can't do anything Testarossa
as he destroys every one of melioidosis
hearts one by one bonds and tears just
as with Elaine he was powerless to help
out his friend all he did was watch both
of them die Anja vago sacrificed his
soul bond using all of his power
couldn't even slow Estero sat down while
Esther also destroys bonds body
effortlessly without breaking a sweat
of course bonds and mortal body
regenerates but he's reached a new low
in his life at this point he was utterly
powerless to save the people he cared
about the most
Meli onus comes back to life because of
his father's curse but only to later
lose his emotions which are wandering
around in purgatory purgatory is
described to us as a place where the air
is a mix of both burning hot and
freezing cold while the earth is highly
poisonous together they destroy the
flesh and bone of any living thing time
is so distorted that a single minute
lasts for a year it eats away at the
souls of mortals if someone is going to
go after Mel Ulysses emotions they have
to go through those insane conditions
while also being prepared to take all
the demon king himself who is presented
as a God in the world of the seven
deadly sins Merlin's father spent only
one minute in the outside world in
purgatory he went in the strongest of
wizards and came out a wreck of his
former self who couldn't stop raving
about purgatory until his death one
minute in the real world which is one
year in purgatory did this to him so
Merlin knows how harsh purgatory is and
she knows how powerful the demon king is
too which is why she tells everyone to
give up on saving millio toises emotions
everyone is upset either sweating or
crying they're not sure what to do
however bond steps up and calmly says
he'll go despite Merlin warning him that
he probably won't return and will only
wind up dead bond is determined even if
it means
never seeing Elaine again he says please
let me do this I want to save my best
friend if I can't even do that then how
am I supposed to protect the girl I love
bond has finally given up on the idea of
saving one or the other as the sin of
greed should be bond has become greedy
in a sense he wants to save both of them
he feels like his only options to become
strong enough so he can save both
because if he stays as weak as he is he
won't be able to save anyone this is a
vital step in bonds journey towards
atoning for his sins although he used to
believe since can be atoned for he jumps
into purgatory to save Mellie Otis
risking his own life sanity and
relationship with Elaine in the process
while before he tried to kill Mellie
Otis for Elaine now he is willing to
risk never seeing Elaine again in order
to save his best friend bond spends over
1,000 years in purgatory he endured
being burned to ashes freezing to the
bone rotting from deadly poison and more
Mellie Otis has temporarily lost his
sanity and purgatory but bond helps
bring him back to his senses
if not for bond Mellie Otis's emotions
would have probably roamed in purgatory
for eternity later on Mellie Otis let's
bond know that he's incredible for
enduring it all one admits that he can't
count a number of times he was ready to
give up but he didn't and eventually his
body's tolerance level rose and he got
used to the conditions however Mellie
Otis is more impressed that he could
retain his sanity for all this time
remember that Merlin's died completely
lost his sanity by spending one year in
purgatory let alone 1,000 years Vaughan
thinks that maybe he was able to endure
it because he was raised in a total crap
environment as a kid
Mellie Otis brushes this off as a joke
but it is significant that bond would
compare his childhood to purgatory this
really gives us a sense of how much pain
bond actually endured before he met
Siobhan go
Mellie Otis goes on to say that bonds
experience from enduring and adapting to
purgatory has caused an explosive
transformation upon his body and soul
bond is pleased to hear that and he
hopes he's powered up enough to be able
to fight against the 10 commandments
little does he know that he's powered up
enough to be able to fight against the
demon king lord help smelly Otis get out
of purgatory by using his snatch ability
which
even King has taught him to reverse
because the demon king used to drain his
power ba learned how it feels to give
energy rather than take it this new
ability comes in handy when he finally
escapes purgatory after his escape bond
rescues Elaine from a number of demons
with one swipe of his hand
most of these demons are way stronger
than the red demon who killed Elaine in
the past so it's a scene that really
shows how far bond has come then bond
uses his new ability gift to bring Lane
back to life by sacrificing his
immortality in the past
Elaine wished that bond came to steal
her away rather than the Fountain of
Youth and bond promised to do that
someday
well that some day has finally come and
although bond blamed himself for
Elaine's death and you did it as a sin
that could not be atoned for he never
gave up and succeeded in restoring her
life now the two lovers can be together
for the rest of their lives
however bond still has to help Mele ODIs
and the other sins although he could run
away from danger with Elaine he chooses
to risk his now mortal life to help his
best friend one more time
by the time bond shows up to the
battlefield the demon king has taken
over Mele Otis's body he has easily
overpowered everyone who has tried to
attack him and he was even about to kill
hawk but bond saves him his other close
friend the man who was no match for
gallons or molasse Cola is now going
blow for blow with the demon king while
Mele ODIs is fighting on the inside with
the help of everyone but especially bond
who throws the finishing punch the demon
king is defeated and Mele ODIs regains
control of his body thus bond
the man who blamed himself for his
lover's death and for trying to kill his
best friend who believed that sins could
not be atoned for manages to atone for
his sins he helped both of the people he
had wronged and the good definitely
outweighed the bad in the end he
accidentally caused a red demon to turn
around and kill Elaine but he brought
her back to life
not to mention all of the joy and love
he brought into her previously lonely
life then he tried to kill Mele Ottis so
that he could bring back Elaine
but he didn't ultimately go through with
it he felt horrible for what he tried to
do and he felt like he'd never be able
to make it up to him however Chuvalo
convinced him not to give up and
did eventually find a way to make things
right bond risked his life his sanity
his relationship with Elaine in an
attempt to rescue millio Lisa's emotions
from purgatory then he risked his life
again after bringing Elaine back to life
in order to rescue Mele Otis's body from
the demon king he paid his debts many
times over bought experienced painful
events after painful events he went
through a rotten and lonely childhood he
lost the love of his life he was
tortured imprisoned he had to deal with
the guilt of trying to kill his best
friend he lost his father zhivago he
lost his best friend he spent over 1,000
years in purgatory and yet he never gave
up he kept moving forward he made
mistakes
but he worked hard to atone for his sins
and eventually his perseverance and hard
work was rewarded if anyone ever had
reasons to give up and quit it was bond
but he didn't and he was rewarded for it
he managed to bring back a lame and to
save his best friend he went from a
lonely starving and powerless kid and
ended up with the love of his life the
best of friends and the power to help
protect them no matter what happens from
this point on in the story what has
already had the perfect character arc
his story is inspiring in a constant
reminder that even if things seem
utterly hopeless and depressing right
now if you don't give up if you keep
faith things are going to get better
perhaps unimaginably better and that is
it for today's video thank you so much
for watching this was quite the long one
but it was totally worth it bond is one
of my favorite characters in anime and
his story is one of the best let me know
if anything in bonds story inspired you
or resonated with you if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell for more videos like
this one if you enjoyed the video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know
for even more inspiring anime content
follow us on instagram at anime uproar a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make these
videos possible I especially want to
thank our pro tier patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh chubs is the man and
nothing but a fan and are the one tier
patrons the one who stands atop all
clans baby Rey a17 FF DP Steven and
Radha a Lola and autumn Maddie Mac 239
and Michael Calderon if you enjoy our
work and get value from it you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you
[Music]